que el gobierno francesa ya sobrevivido
por poco a dos mociones de censura Pero
eso no ha hecho nada Para calmar el
tenso enfrentamiento tanto en el
parlamento como en las calles y ahora
qué pasa con el proyecto de ley de
pensiones del presidente macron lo
posiciona aún tiene opciones para hacer
descarrilar la reforma podría solicitar
una revisión por parte del Consejo
constitucional de Francia este órgano
tiene el poder de modificar los
proyectos de ley o anularlos por
completo si los considera
inconstitucionales los líderes
parlamentarios de los grupos de
izquierdas y derechas dentro de la
asamblea nacional ya han dicho que
solicitarán una revisión judicial así
como la primera administrada Elizabeth o
traducción abierta a la oposición es
convocar un referéndum para que se
organice un referéndum es necesario que
al menos una quinta parte de los
legisladores franceses se adhieran a la
propuesta es decir 185 de los 925
senadores y diputados que componen las
cámaras alta y baja del parlamento
francés luego necesitaría el respaldo de
al menos una décima parte de los
votantes con derecho a vudú es decir
4.85 millones de personas que
dispondrían de nueve meses para
manifestar su apoyo a la organización de
una votación Incluso si la legislación
de macron supera esos obstáculos las
esperanzas de la oposición podrían
recibir en las protestas callejeras en
2006 los planes del gobierno de para
introducir un controvertido contrato de
trabajo juvenil fueron archivados tras
semanas de manifestaciones masivas la
lucha no ha terminado es como lo que
pasó con el contrato de trabajo juvenil
mientras no se aplique la ley Seguiremos
luchando
los sindicatos ya han convocado una
jornada de paros masivos y protestas
para este juez